hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt's eine motiv torte und zwar
sind wir später auf einer taufe
eingeladen und ich habe gesagt ich mach
die taufe wurde luisa wird getauft das
es übrigens amiras beste freundin die
kraft immer die ganze zeit zusammen vom
ok momentan krabbeln sind unterliegen er
herum
ela rollt drüber klappte luisa den
schnuller und rollt wieder zurück aber
krabbeln bestimmte nicht luisa wird
getauscht und zwingen habe ich eine
zweistöckige motiv torte gebacken ihnen
habe ich einen wiener boden mit einer f
kaputter creme und hast du dann
eigentlich ganz so schlicht ist sie
nicht so ganz
aber irgendwie schon als auch unten
diese kleinen rüschen und hier oben dann
einfach mit blumen modelliert also das
thema ist so ein bisschen weiß rosa
weiße perlen und blumen
deswegen habe ich mich so bitte daran
orientiert und die torte eben auch so
dekoriert und ich würde sagen ich starte
direkt und zeigt euch wie ich das
gemacht habe ich nur sitz für die torte
ein bisschen was vorbereiten ich habe
jetzt bereits 3000 wurden gebacken und
was wenn es wieder böden und da hab ich
die rezepte bereits auf meinem blog die
habe ich jetzt mit einer erdbeer creme
und mit erdbeer marmelade gefüllt und
die stehen jetzt im kühlschrank
jetzt muss ich immer mal wieder die
torten nehmen und dann zum beispiel auch
mit ghanas bestreichen und später mit
von dor einkleiden und die zwischenzeit
nutze ich jetzt um die dekoration
herzustellen und zwar muss ich jetzt
zuerst einmal die tecco herstellen die
austrocknen muss also durch trocknen
muss das sind jetzt zuerst mal die
blumen und da zeige ich euch jetzt mal
die erste variante zuerst nämlich jetzt
etwas blüten passte blüten paste ist
zwar wie von der aber da ist ganz viel
zellulose pulver drin und deswegen
härtet die gut aus und der vorteil von
blüten passt ace ich kann sie ganz dünn
ausrollen und es mache ich jetzt hier
auf etwas länger stärke
ich hab die blüten passt ganz dünn
ausgerollt und jetzt habe ich ein paar
ausstecher das sind jetzt keine
besonderen blumen ausstecher sondern
einfach diese rosetten ausstecher dies
zb auch bei der weihnachtsbäckerei gibt
da habe ich jetzt vier verschiedene
größen und braucht jetzt für die blume
die jetzt hersteller die sie dann
ungefähr so aus brauche ich von jeder
größe jeweils 2
ja
damit die teils nicht austrocknen lege
ich jetzt unter die silikon matte
verliert keine silikon matte habt könnt
ihr zum beispiel auch frischhaltefolie
nehmen
jetzt nehme ich immer zwei von jeder
sorte
es braucht jetzt bei werkzeuge und zwar
einmal diesen ball toll und einmal
diesen dieses spitze werkzeug
jetzt nehmen sie zuerst wollten und legt
immer ein blütenblatt auf eine
schaumstoffmatten und zwar weil ich
jetzt immer mit dem wollten zuerst von
innen nach außen
und dann immer einmal komplett außen
herum damit auch daran richtig schön
dünn
und jetzt nehmt ihr euch dieses spitze
werkzeug und können damit jetzt ein
bisschen struktur rein bringen und zwar
hier immer am rand ein bisschen
eindrücken und wer dieses werkzeug nicht
hat kann zum beispiel auch einen
zahnstocher oder einen schaschlikspieß
nehmen damit geht es auch ganz gut
ich habe alles vorbereitet jetzt braucht
ihr etwas runde zählt dieser deko
schalen also dass unsere discokugel
ihr könnt aber auch beispielsweise
kleine teller nehmen oder ich glaube wir
mal april verkauft da gibt's auch diese
kleinen apfel schälen die kann man auch
benutzen
jedenfalls braucht jetzt jeweils eins
und legt jetzt immer das größte blatt
zuerst hinein
das kommt unten hin zu bekommt die blume
später einfach so eine schöne runde und
einem wird einfach etwas lebendiger
es kommt hier ein klecks lebensweg
kleber rein wirklich nur ein ganz
kleiner punkt und dann kommt das nächste
blatt rein also zweimal die gleiche
größe und dann immer kleiner werden
sobald die blumen jetzt etwas an
getrocknet sind kann ich sie weiter
dekorieren passieren bis in pulver farbe
ihr könnt die blume ist natürlich auch
so lassen
aber ich werde es noch ein bisschen
rosales pulver drüber geben einfach für
einen tollen effekt hier am rand
und dann kommt etwas kleber in die mitte
und back lebe ich ein paar perlen reihen
jetzt bereite ich eine weitere blume vor
und zwar nehmen jetzt dafür modelle
schokolade in weiß er wie es bereits
weiß geknetet und nehmen jetzt immer
kleines stückchen und formen sie zu
einer kugel und haben dann ungefähr
einen durchmesser von zwei zentimetern
und in die kugel stecke ich dann einen
cache post sich hinein
der geht dann ungefähr bis zur mitte den
drückte dann gut fest
und dann stecke ich die kugel erst
einmal noch hier auf seinem kopf ständer
damit sie da etwas erhalten kann
sobald die kugeln getrocknet sind und
ausgehärtet sind können wir weitermachen
und zwar sieht die blume am ende so aus
das heißt ich habe jetzt hier nochmal
weise modelliert schokolade ausgerollt
und rosanna ausgerollt und habe zwei
verschiedene ausstecher der eine hat in
etwa zwei zentimeter im durchmesser
unter andere 3 ihr könnt aber zum
beispiel auch deckel nehmen und andere
gegenstände die ihr zuhause findet jetzt
nehmt ihr zuerst den kleinen aus
stechert damit habe ich jetzt einen
kleinen weißen kreis ausgestochen und es
kommt etwas kleber auf die kugel
verstreicht jetzt am besten mit einem
pinsel
und da kommt jetzt ein kreis obendrauf
den drückt ihr flach und damit der kreis
jetzt ein bisschen struktur bekommt
nämlich hier einen lebensmittel
farbstift und spät mit dem deckel hier
oben
das ganze strukturieren
jetzt kommt die zweite größe da legt ihr
jetzt fünf blätter außen rum und ihr
dürft ihr auch gleich direkt an kleben
und da kommt immer drauf damit das
nächste blatt auch gut klebt
jetzt verschwindet das letzte blatt noch
unter dem ersten
blättert drücke ich jetzt gut fest
jetzt kommt noch mal eine kleberschicht
obendrauf
und jetzt werde ich hier sieben
rosenblütenblätter aufkleben und zwar so
dass sie immer versetzt sind
und auch hier die blütenblätter wieder
gut andrücken
ja
parallel für blumen herstellung werde
ich jetzt alle torten noch mit von dort
ein gleiten
ich habe jetzt die blumen alle fertig
vorbereitet die können jetzt erstmal
trocknen und jetzt werde ich die untere
etage bereits dekorieren ich habe jetzt
hier weiße von dort mit etwas cnc pulver
verknetet delle rose pulver und bewegt
dass es einfach schneller aushärtet
kommt billerbecker stärke drunter und
ich werde es jetzt ganz dünn ausrollen
und das geht am besten mit namen
nudelholz mit einer nudelmaschine oder
mit einem ausfall starb und in der
nudelmaschine geht es halt ein bisschen
schneller
dieser lange streifen wird jetzt zurecht
geschnitten uns wahrscheinlich da ist
immer zwei zentimeter lange bänder
das mache ich jetzt hier mit einem
bisschen glück aber wir können natürlich
auch ein ganz normales marzipan messer
benutzen oder
jetzt nämlich wieder den rollstuhl und
werde die eine seite etwas dünner machen
jetzt bestreite ich die torte mit etwas
kleber dafür gebe ich denke kleber jetzt
in ein kleines schälchen und nimmt an
einem breiten pinsel und geht es etwas
schneller
damit sie erstmal den oberen rand
jetzt lebe ich dieses band hier oben
dran und es darf auch ruhig ein bisschen
überlappen
hinten kommt es einen index nach unten
dann schneide ich da weg und dann lege
ich das andere drüber dann sieht man
auch fast keinen übergang
mit den fingern kann es da noch ein
bisschen nur weil ich geformt werden
und die anderen länder die werden jetzt
drunter geklebt und zwar immer
überlappend dass man wie so eine art
wellengang hat
jetzt werde ich die mittlere etage
dekorieren dafür habe ich jetzt hier
bereits einen kreis aus weißer modelle
schokolade ausgestochen und den gebe ich
jetzt mit ich an
jetzt stehe ich noch ein paar blumen aus
ausrufer modelle schokolade und die
sätze ich dann gleich auf einen
schaumstoff pet
jetzt schreibe ich hier noch ein dünnes
band aus und daraus werde ich jetzt ganz
schneller rosen machen und zwar nimmt
ihr das band in die hand und faltet es
und dann wären die eingedreht und ruhig
so ein bisschen in falten legen
und am ende war mit einer schere
abschneiden
jetzt werde ich die ganzen dekoelemente
hier vorne noch draufkleben und zum
schluss den namen dran schreiben und
zwar nehme ich jetzt die kleinen rosen
und die verstecke ich jetzt mit einem
zahnstocher den traurig in etwas kleber
den habe ich vorher halbiert
jetzt kann ich die rose ganz einfach
hier dran kleben
bis mittlere stockwerk werde ich jetzt
hier oben noch eine kleine schleife
herstellen darf nämlich cd rosa an der
modelle schokolade und schneit es ein
dünnes band aus deshalb um so etwa 4 mm
breite und dann schneide ich einen ca 3
cm langes stück davon ab und jetzt die
enden so ein bisschen einknicken und
hinlegen und dann hier in der mitte noch
ein bisschen eindrücken und da etwas
kleber drauf streichen
jetzt werden die zwei äusseren teile
nach innen eingeklappt
nehmt ihr euch ein ganz kleines
stückchen modelle schokolade und knetet
durch form zu einer kleinen rolle und es
kommt dann noch mit ich drüber
und damit es nicht zu flach aussieht
hier nochmal mit einem pinsel oder mit
einem dünnen gegenstand rein und hier
oben noch zwei striche markieren und so
sieht jetzt die fertige schleife aus dem
rest kann ich jetzt noch zwei kleine
bender schneiden
jetzt habe ich hier noch ein paar blumen
ausgestochen und jetzt werde ich noch
mal aus blüten passte blumen machen und
zwar jetzt die böden passte wieder ganz
den ausgerollt und nehmen diesen blumen
ausstecher
ja
und dann nehme ich jetzt wieder einen
schaumstoff pad und einen ball toll und
werde jetzt die ränder wieder etwas
ausdehnen
und damit die blumen etwas realistischer
aussehen könnte sie in diese blumen
schälchen reinlegen
da werden sie so ein bisschen halbrund
oder legte zum beispiel ein esslöffel
das geht auch gut jetzt alle
dekoelemente fertig und jetzt kann ich
die torte zusammensetzen
es brauche ich natürlich ein paar am
steht damit ich die obere torte jetzt
drauf setzen kann
wenn ich jetzt keine stäbe dem zum
stabilisieren da kann es passieren dass
die obere torte ein sinkt weil er die
unter nicht stabil genug ist deswegen
nehme ich jetzt ganz gerne cake pops
ticks und ihr könnt aber zum beispiel
auch wird diese ganz dicken strohhalm
nehmen oder sogar holzstäbe so
rundhölzer vom baumarkt zum beispiel das
mache ich direkt einfach in die mitte
und schaut ob es von der länge her passt
dann mag ich jetzt hier einmal die
längen mit einem lebensmittel stift und
kann jetzt alle anderen noch zurecht
schneiden
jetzt kommt ein stäbchen gleich in die
mitte und die restlichen com jetzt außen
rum und da muss man jetzt nur aufpassen
dass man sie nicht zu weit nach außen
setzt
und da ist die torte transportieren
werde werde ich jetzt hier noch etwas
ganz streichen damit die torte anklebt
und beim transport nicht verrutscht
jetzt kann ich mit etwas essbarem kleber
die blumen noch am leben und bin damit
orte fertig
die tat ist fertig dekoriert und so
gefällt es mir eigentlich ganz gut vor
allem mit den blumen mit dem verlauf
hier nach unten so hatte sich die
sabrina die torte gewünscht dass die
mama von luisa und die torte ist ein
bisschen feucht geworden weil hier drin
ist es wirklich sehr warm ich glaube
wenn schon über 25 grad in der küche und
es ist wirklich eine totale hitze aber
hat den vorteil ich konnte hier noch ein
paar perlen aufkleben und die einfach so
bisher darauf schmeißen die hatte
nämlich schon ganz alleine
jedenfalls kann man die motiv steht
trotzdem im kühlschrank lagern man muss
nur aufpassen dass der kühlschrank nicht
zu feucht ist und da am besten ein
schildchen mit salz reinstellen
dann sieht dem ich das als die
feuchtigkeit ja ich hoffe dass ich diese
torte gefallen hat vielleicht möchtest
dir jemand nachmachen
ich werde demnächst natürlich auch mal
motiv torten für jungs machen wo es
immer ein bissl blöd findet mädchen und
jungs aber irgendwie wünschen sich die
mamas und papas ist trotzdem von mir so
deswegen werde ich demnächst eine jungen
motiv zu machen wahrscheinlich zu einem
ersten geburtstag oder eventuell auch
zur taufe und vielleicht habt ihr da
auch ein paar wünsche und vorschläge
dann mache ich dir gerne nach und jetzt
wünsche ich ganz viel spaß beim
nachbacken und dekorieren und wir sehen
uns beim nächsten mal wieder biss dann
tschüss und die rezepte gibt es -
blog.de ja